i was born in baku azerbaijan in the
USSR at that time in 1963 with a Jewish
father and an Armenian mother I was
raised as a Soviet with a dominant
Russian culture I was always very
political by nature and on the road to
the World Championship this led me into
frequent conflicts with the authorities
since chess was considered an important
tool to promote the intellectual
superiority of the users are over the
decadent West needless to say my
frequent pro-western statements did not
gain me any favour at home as a young
man in a tease I looked to America as a
symbol of the values and freedom I
wanted for my own country today I live
in New York City and unfortunately I'm
still fighting for freedom for my
country Russia two years ago for reasons
beyond my control I moved from Russia to
New York but I spent much of my life in
between Europe for centuries Europe was
the center of the civilized world the
center of power and of the ideas that
move the world forward politics
technology philosophy industry it all
came together in Europe and was exported
to the rest of the world Europe is also
the birthplace of the modern world order
the concept of consensus and borders but
the dynamic growth centers today are
America and Asia and grows is what gets
the most attention not ideas or
philosophy Europe is called old
continent the old world as if the rest
of the world is saying thank you but we
took what we need it and don't need you
anymore but those who say these are very
wrong dangerous the wrong and we need
the ideas and leadership of Europe today
more than ever it is ironic that Europe
today is back on the front line of the
war and modernity in the 20th century
Europe was home to some of the wars
Horrors humanity has ever seen
yet today Europe represents peace unity
and the power of enlightenment ideals to
unite but the forces of the past of
brutality and violence are attacking the
free world here where it was war
religious extremists use Europe's
openness against it to launch terror
attacks a dictator challenges the
borders and alliances of Europe for the
first time since the end of World War
two what succeeds or fails here will set
the course for the rest of the world as
has been the case for centuries Europe
must not fail Europe must not fall our
goal must be to help those stuck in the
past to join the present and it cannot
be done only by force we must be sincere
and make an overwhelmingly attractive
case but this does not mean cutting or
tolerating violent extremist or those
who create them at home or abroad an
open society that cannot defend its
citizens will not be open for with for
very long symbols matters in this fight
symbols like Charlie abdur and
photographs of the world leaders
marching together for free speech it is
not enough to tell our immigrants our
citizens and the billions of souls still
living in the am free world that this
ideas matter we must show them the
terrorists and their teachers and the
dictators and their enables our quick to
point out every hypocrisy every double
standard we cannot compromise for as
Victor Hugo Road in the toilers of the
sea men grow accustomed to poison by
degrees in my mind the first drop of
poison on European soil was ayatollah
khomeini's fatra for death against
british citizen the authors oven rooted
in 1989 while ruthless life was
protected britain even under Margaret
Thatcher and the free world failed to
stand up to this unprecedented attack on
Rudi's freedom of speech that was in
fact a great deal of sympathy about how
his book The Satanic Verses of
banded Muslims jump forward to 2006 when
British citizen Alexander Litvinenko the
former Russian intelligence officer who
exposed many crimes by the Putin's
regime was assassinated in London with
the ready radioactive substance
polonium-210 the suspect fled back to
Russia were not only was he protected
from extradition but he promptly joined
the Russian parliament I can't say
elected it was Putin's way of showing
how little he cared about the rule of
law and yet Britain and the rest of the
world continue to do business with Putin
and with Russia and the investigation
into the first case of nuclear terrorism
was put on the shelf until recently on
July 17 2014 Malaysia Airlines flight 17
was shot down or Eastern Ukrainian
territory occupied by invading Russian
and Russian that forces 298 people were
killed including 193 Dutch citizens the
scene of the crash was controlled by the
same Russian forces that are now nearly
unanimously blamed for shooting down MH
17 and yet it was not only Russia that
denied responsibility Europe was quick
to embrace any uncertainty and eager to
avoid any confrontation but as evidence
continues to accumulate that there is no
doubt the plane was shot down by Russian
forces and the Russian control then what
Putin will refused to cooperate of
course and then what will it still be
business as usual more engagement and
more futile attempts to find a win-win
situation the attitude of finding
win-win situations admirable in some
ways of course it will be wonderful if
every crisis or conflict could be ended
to mutual benefit but assuming that can
happen with Isis or with Putin ignores
the true nature of the enemy Putin's
only goal is to stay in power and he has
moved beyond the need for cooperation
with the free world to do that he needs
conflict and hatred now and how do you
negotiate
with that with that without betraying
your ideals and your people our Qaeda
and Isis want to cut off the modern
world of individual freedom how does a
pluralistic illiberal society negotiate
with that world you to mutual benefit it
cannot at some point reality must be
faced Western society has become
dangerous the risk averse and even more
eager to believe blatantly contradictory
messages we ask for low taxes but expect
more government services we demand
protection while insisting on privacy
that we must sacrifice something even
our lives for the values that make our
society wars protecting has been
forgotten the idea of individual liberty
was the West sharpest sword in winning
the Cold War but it has been bitten into
plush air and now we must arm ourselves
once more but most consumers in the
developed world would rather not know
where their phones and gas come from as
long as the prices are low the
occasional scandal over unhuman working
conditions in Chinese factories or
Vietnamese or Burmese is quickly and
conveniently forgotten when the next
shoe or next gadget comes out the recent
protests in Hong Kong or another
refutation what I have mockingly
referred to as the genetic concept of
democracy this is just one of many
theories people born in the free world
used to mask their privilege their
inaction and their shame for years I've
been told that Russians or Arabs or
Chinese simply are not disposed to
democracy they require strong hand or
they love a tough leader condescending
and ridiculous when you look at the two
germanys the two Koreas China and Taiwan
and of course now at Ukraine and Russia
what is true is that no one is simply
entitled to democracy or even to basic
human rights know these things must
always be fought for many who speak out
in favor of a comma
leading Putin and his aggression in
Ukraine are quick to warn us of the
threat of a new Cold War this use of
cliche today is ironic since how the
Cold War was fought and won has been
forgotten instead of emulated instead of
standing on principles of good and evil
of right and wrong and on the universal
values of human rights and human life we
have engagements resets and moral
equivalence the Cold War was not one
just by military or economic superiority
but on values I as former Soviet citizen
and ironically used to call traditional
American values or more broadly Western
values but these terms are obsolete
today even offensive as I said and it's
a duty of every democracy not just the
United States and and Western Europe but
of every free and open society from
Brazil to Japan from South Africa to
Korea to defend these values chief among
them is the belief that individual
freedom matters and it's worth
sacrificing for fighting for even dying
for the best enemies are those against
whom there are historical conflicts to
resuscitate for KGB man Putin and his
clique it has been most natural to drum
up anti-americanism preying on all Cold
War memories another popular target are
those members of society who cannot
effectively fight back the outsiders and
ethnic and sexual minorities who are
already under great pressure due to the
destruction of civil society let us be
clear what we are dealing with in his
2004 book the anatomy of fascism famous
historian Robert Paxton provided this
concise definition fascism may be
defined as a form of political behavior
marked by obsessive preoccupation with
community decline humiliation or weak
team hood and by compensatory cults of
unity energy impurity
in which a mass stays party of committed
national militants working in an easy
but effective collaborations traditional
eat abandons democratic liberties and
pursues with redemptive violence and
without ethical or legal restraints goal
of internal cleansing and external
expansion the end of quote previously
Italian philosopher Umberto Eco
contributed a list of 14 general
properties of fascist ideology that are
also terrifyingly familiar to any
observer of Putin's Russia today while
our ever-evolving opposition movement
made some progress in drawing attention
to the increasingly fascist reality of
Putin's Russia we were in a losing
position from the start the Kremlin
domination of the mass media and who's
this prosecution of our position in
civil society made is impossible to
build any lasting momentum our mission
was also sabotage by Democratic leaders
embracing put on the world stage
providing him with the leadership
credentials he so badly needed in the
absence of light of a valid elections in
Russia in today's era of globalization
and false equivalence it can be hard for
many of us to recall that most call
world leaders had seen true evil close
up close during world war two they had
no illusions about what dictators were
capable capable of if given the chance
they had witness existential threats
with their own eyes seen the horror of
the concentration camps and the use of
nuclear weapons in war in some ways it's
a shame that today the names of advil
Hitler and Joseph Stalin have become
caricatures as if they are mythological
beasts representing an ancient evil that
was vanquished long ago but it will does
not die just as history does not end
like a weed Evo can be cut back but
almost never entirely entirely uprooted
it waits for a chance to spread through
the cracks in our vigilance it takes
root in the fertile soil of our
complacency
like the dragon of the Greek myth whose
teeth sprouted from the ground as
soldiers the Berlin Wall fell in pieces
and many of those pieces contain the
seeds of evil nor did communism
disappear when the Wall fell nearly 1.5
billion humans still live in communist
dictatorships today and another billion
and a half live in an free states of
different stripes including of course
much of the former Soviet Union the
desire of men to exploit and to rule
over others by diktat and by force did
not disappear what did disappear or at
least what faded dramatically was the
willingness of the free world to take a
firm stand in support of their pressed
the wall fell and the world exhaled the
longer war of generations was over the
threat of nuclear annihilation that hang
over all our heads was ending Victor's
however even great victories come at a
cost I've written about what i call the
gravity of past success in chess the
gravity of past success winning feels
great but they can also inhibit your
development they'll loosen knows he made
a mistake and that something went wrong
and he will work hard to improve the
happy winner on the other hand often
assumes he wants simply because he's
great it takes tremendous discipline to
learn lessons from a victory the world
needs a new alliance based on the new
Magna Carta a declaration of rights and
practices that all member nations must
recognize nations that value democracy
and individual liberty now control the
greater part of the world resources as
well as its military power if we band
together and refuse to coddle the rogue
regimes and sponsors of terror our
authority will be irresistible our
combined Wells can also found new
technologies to cure our fossil fuel
addiction which currently empowers a
majority of the terrorists and dictators
the goal should not be built new
also isolate the millions of people
living under authoritarian rule but to
come to their 8th United military
intervention to protect human lives and
the greater good might also be kept on
the table the value of human life and
the value of human freedom in the new
Magna Carta must be defended as if they
were borders for that is that what they
are they're our boarders of time and
space separating those who want to leave
in the modern world and those who
modernity is a mortal threat I advocate
for return to many of the principles and
policies that were dominant in the West
during the Cold War but what does not
mean it does not mean I want to turn
back the clock as the Bible says no one
pours new wine into old white wine skins
otherwise the wine will birth the skins
and both the wine and the wine skins
would be ruined we cannot pour the
modern wine of globalization and the
multipolar world into the old wineskins
of the obsolete Cold War rules and
regulations from the United Nations
times change circumstances change
institutions must change but our values
must not thank